Honorable speaker my name is
I'm an engineer by profession
men and women are equal in Islam why
there was no prophet
there was a question that men and women
are equal in Islam why were not there
prophets in Islam as I told you the
verse of the Quran of surah bakar
chapter 2 number 228. The men have
rights as equal to them as against them.
But a degree of advantage in leadership
in leadership it is the man. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in his divine
wisdom. You know when a prophet comes he
has to lead the salah. If a woman leads
the salah and men are behind her they
will concentrate on the woman more than
Allah. Correct?
>> Do you understand?
So the Islamic mandate and normally if
you see even in politics what is there
you find the head of the state normally
goes and meets with others the
interaction there is photography
everything is there so this breaks the
hijab so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala did
not want to put a burden on the woman
because in women if you there there was
a research done in Canada by two female
scientists
she said that the women have verbal
qualities which is required for
upbringing children. The men have
spatial qualities in thinking and
planning. So men are more involved in
planning as leaders as compared to
women. But in verbal qualities in
upbringing taking care of the child the
woman has. It is for a woman to take
care of the child and be a prophet would
be doubled. You know what taking care of
the child is not easy. You know you are
a man I'm a man.
So it's a blessing from Allah. That is
the reason Allah the prophet said mother
mother because it's a different role
altogether. So for prophethood because
leadership is required the special
qualities more in men. There are things
like leading the salah there are things
like planning. There are things like
going for jihad women can go but the men
are more capable. So for that THE REASON
I THINK in my own way that the reason
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala did not want
to overburden the woman but there are
many women which have been praised in
the Quran for example may Allah be
pleased with her
Allah says in the Quran in surah Iran 3
verse number 43 Allah says
that Allah has chosen in thee and
purified thee and purified thee among
the women of all nations. So you have
the example of mother Mary
not a prophet but
she's chosen above the woman of all
nations. You have the example of
Khadijah may Allah be pleas with her who
was the wife of the prophet.
We have the example in the Quran of Assa
who was the wife of Allah mentioned
about her in surahim chapter 66 verse
number 11 that she prays to Allah that I
would like to change exchange all the
wealth in this world. She was the wife
of the most powerful man in the world
for a place of a house in Jenna close to
Allah. You have for example you have the
example of may Allah be pleased with her
who was the daughter of the prophet. So
you have examples of many women who are
great but Allah in his divine wisdom
chose the men for the role is different.
Hope that answers the question.
animal.